you have gaining progression laid to
rest next to his father in his home city
of Saint Petersburg
no pomper ceremony and no military
honors despite being awarded Russia's
highest Military Award the hero of
Russia medal
only a few dozen people and security
guards were at the private ceremony for
the Wagner leader
notably absent Russian President
Vladimir Putin
the president is not planning on
attending it we don't have any specific
information on that funeral this
decision is being made by pregosian's
family and friends
Services were also held for other
leaders of the mercenary group
they included Valerie chakalov Wagner's
head of logistics public support for
Wagner appears to be strong in Russia
with a makeshift Memorial set up in
Moscow
it's a big tragedy for our people may
the memory of the heroes live forever we
should remember them because these
people determine the direction of
development for all our people
the entire country is mourning all
sober-minded people are mourning and
worrying about this person and about all
Wagner Fighters and our guys
the Kremlin says pagosian and nine
others were killed when the Wagner
private jet crashed in the tavier region
just north of the capital
the Kremlin maintains that it wasn't
involved in the death of Putin's former
Ally 62 year old evgeny pagosian was
laid to rest in purokovskaya Cemetery
about 15 kilometers from here no one
from the public was allowed to enter the
burial ground since his funeral it
appears the hero of Russia continues to
be a controversial figure even in death
Al Jazeera St Petersburg
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera